I'm a little late join the hourly super
blitz about 41 minutes left number 100
okay so the goal is to get from 100 okay
now from 101 to number 1 in about 40
minutes hopefully they'll start the game
soon yeah this mug has like a lid so
it's it's kind of spill proof lid is
hard to maneuver okay let's play let's
play Zurich and let's play e5 and let's
the plane xe6 whoa do I have another tab
open I have another tab open that was
kind of weird okay things are now fixed
let's develop castle the bishop on b2 is
blocked by the the d4 pawn but it still
has some influence controlling a5 so the
goal is to prevent ninety five which is
basically the purpose of row heats
methane bro first in the chat welcome
and InfoSec how's it going if you're
just joining I'm playing Super glitz
three-minute chests my first game of the
tournament has irked I poured some tea I
played f5 I want to play Queen at six
maybe the rook belongs here in the other
roof belongs elsewhere it's interesting
move this is a move like the
counter-attack against f2 kind of sack a
piece I don't really have much time to
think
let's take a bishop maybe I'll win the
pawn takes okay yeah I'm winning upon or
am i takes takes takes takes this move
oh then I have necks III in the end
that'll be nice it's a small trap I'd
see three still it's a fork yeah I both
903 and f3 were mistakes never put
anything on f3 it's usually a mistake
okay this is still gonna take work
though because I need to not flag and
activate my queen and rook probably
that's Knight as a monster maybe I'll
play a five a four or maybe this move
yeah
pinning and trying to win the pawn mmm
c4 defending let's play this move I
think I want to trade a pair of rooks c5
oh let's play this move keeping the pin
attacking the pawn expecting this move
I'll play this move attacking this pawn
threatening the the fork ooh the fork
has arrived yeah for some reason
sideways Queen moves are sometimes hard
to spot attacking this pawn plenty of
time
I see people in the chats but I want to
finish the scheme but fly I interact too
much okay let's push up on
I want to push more pawns yeah next
several moves will leave Han moves b6 c5
maybe I'll just put the rook on the 8th
and go for mates like rookie a queen h2
Queen each one rook c2 is coming or that
I keep pushing keep pushing
that's a check ok hard to defend the
night cream of this I'll play this move
next
or this move
where's the meats here's a meat okay
hello to people Luxio welcome back
little bread lobster Columbo pepper WC
saying go go go Eric how long have you
been playing chess I have a Wikipedia
page that answers that question so I
don't have to go to type in exclamation
point wiki in the chat and that will
give you my background also shout-out to
Schwab in chess who probably isn't
watching
but Robin chests made the Wikipedia page
a reality
so let's preserve again let's play the
London try and start off solidly III
there's a cool line g4 I think I saw
Carlson play this once on me chess and
it looks kind of cool
not sure if it's like so correct but it
looks fun I'm pushing pawns early I got
the g5 movement already I have slightly
bizarre pawn structure but I want to
play off three at the Knights and maybe
after this I can take oh and IG three I
forgot about that they work each to
swing over eventually that's a little
bit strange probably moved a few too
many pawns on the Kings side let's play
this move defending what are your PC
specs I actually don't know all the
details because this this is essentially
the chess Brock come here and it was
here when I moved in but I'm pretty sure
the specs are are pretty nice
there have been some technical issues
but but overall it's pretty fast there's
three monitors there's internet
everything I need articles being
considered for deletion that's not good
I didn't know that I'll have to look
into that but let's focus on chess I
think maybe because it's new it might be
under review okay let's not get too much
trouble this game one play Knight c3 and
hit the bishop well I guess if the if
the page is getting more views and more
traffic then hopefully that will support
the case for it not getting deleted I'm
counter-attacking the bishop and this is
a move Oh that's also a move I could
vote test gambit
I've been overusing the word bow test
gambit a lot lately oh dear how about
that move Oh No
okay this is like a real bow test Canada
where I'm just oh also uh huh oh this is
really bad I only hope his back rank
mates I just lost everything
why did I bow test gambit oh this is so
bad I mean the opponent has a rook two
for maybe please play Queen g3 please
just mouse whip hitting the Queen at
least half open file aligned with a king
let's move
hmm yeah this is not good I don't think
I'm gonna try and survive though
hope for stalemate
like the grand chess to her ding
stalemated sounded vivid and some like
completely winning I'm game okay
crashing through opponent giving me no
mercy so little mercy no there's no hope
for stalemate because there's too many
pawns
well played to my opponent yeah well I
initially sack the Queen I forgot um
vision makes each is possible because I
would just looked at this and then this
and then it would be okay cuz that force
stays defended this was really bad I
just didn't see the brook was attacked I
don't have any ways to save my rook and
my Knights what to do fake oh thanks for
subbing appreciate that we need a potato
emoji well we have a toilet noggin emoji
which I think it's suitable for that key
[Music]
clamp key okay well I was trying to win
the tournaments but it might be
difficult given that I just lost a game
and there's 30 minutes left but it's
still possible let's play this move I'm
gonna try and be aggressive I have to
play much quicker - it's really
interesting Bishop let's play this move
the spawn you have been hanging I won't
play III I'll play III it just slows
down development opens efile Wow
what is F for what is that for do I
haven't made somewhere
sir at this move defend the pawn g5
might be suitable soon as pawns like
somewhat invincible it's not easy to
attack let's just keep stacking stuff
that takes b5 some of castling let's
play of this move I'm just going all-out
for me I don't care about the rest of my
pieces okay I can take here mmm play
this move I want to take I want to do
this and then take on g3 next King f3 my
queen trapped my Queens kind of trapped
what do I do
do I do here I could vote as gamma the
gang I would be slightly questionable I
don't see what to do I guess I'll bow
Ted's gambit again cuz why not oh I
wasn't not expecting the Queen to take
but that's okay it's still reasonable
maybe all queenside castle or I'll take
a free bishop how this is hanging
opponent didn't see it let's take this
and a castle okay I'm up at Bishop
plenty of time it's only up a bishop my
queen was trapped earlier I was sacking
stuff and going after this pawn to do
play g4 and Bishop here I'll play Bishop
c4 never mind
11 seconds hmm I gotta move a little bit
faster
okay two connected passers
I'm threading B - actually yeah let's
play smooth
I'm just playing safe free moves there
we go okay well the key was nasty game
on many different levels like the
opening the middle game and endgame
there's too much nastiness okay I must
play like a caveman to win this at 26
minutes left only six points the dark
against the e4od for caveman chucks
see three Danish gambit my opponent
except I guess not
I wanna play Bishop g5 opponent had plan
takes b2
it's a queen with supporting it takes
takes I have to play Knight ft2 or no
I'm just losing material
let's sack the sack the rook works are
less valuable in the middle game okay so
I saw two pawns and the rook definitely
caveman chess and queen h5 will maybe be
ma threats
Queen takes I have rook e1 the only say
square for the knight is to move back
where it came from
now I'm threatening maiden too
yeah now I'm turning this and then this
and then this expecting Queen Daisy five
it's still not entirely clear actually
okay now it should be pretty clear made
in one two three I'll never mind let's
play this move and then Queen at four
and go for meet the AL docks pieces not
really helping the defense Queen our six
coming another like not such great
quality game I'm getting the job done
this can be pre moves this can be pre
moves okay doctor tournaments where am i
I'm top hundred twenty-one not that
twenty-one still need to catch up nine
points nine away from first place but
it's gonna take some time and by the
time I get to eighteen this person will
probably be a bit higher so I have to
just keep as irking and not lose what do
you do on your free time ice cream ice
cream super blitz let's let's blizzard
and let's play e5 YaST after gambit time
let's go never played this opponent
before so hopefully this opponent
doesn't know my my secrets
Oh Bonin knows what to do though I'm
fighting meets Queen f3 one is very
booked up okay this is reasonable I
think chef g4 I want to queenside castle
let's not treat Queens
this is hanging but pawns are not too
relevant
let's queenside castle now well I can't
queenside castle it's like control a d1
square ooh
[Music]
hmm this Bishop c5 a move Bishop c5 a
move developing developing a final minor
piece if takes I made into 1 2 and I'm
threatening this which is devastating
maybe rook f8 to come I'm not
calculating I mean both bishops attacked
by pawns hopefully it's okay though if
it takes I take with Knights hmm it's a
little bit sketchy
let's play this mm-hmm and both bishops
hanging so much regrets if takes I'll
take here and then hopefully take on c5
next I want to play this and eventually
this I have to remove the knight first
let's take here and maybe what to do I
take on II to
I don't know why I'm doing this I'm
sacking more material because it looks
fun it's probably really dubious but
that night was annoying me
night takes I have a g5 maybe g5g five
solves all my problems sometimes Oh does
this not work this doesn't work
okay maybe g5 didn't solve all my
problems
hmm yeah that's a little bit troublesome
Queen f7 oh this is very troublesome do
I not have any defense
don't have any defense Oh No okay oh
this is really bad I have a bishop
hanging I'm down a Brooke bishop in some
pawns but I've hope where do i what am i
threatening threatening 94 maybe I'll
get the knight to d3 but it's difficult
I found the pawn trying to pin hmm
oh this is really bad push the H pawn
next I see four ideas there we go no
okay pulling this Franky's ah I flagged
oh so sad I don't think I'm gonna win
this remnant I was a really messy game I
[Music]
was too optimistic with sacking
everything also bulky aura thanks for
thanks for subbing for two months
yeah after this treatment I'll settle
down I'll play some longer I'll play
more instructive chess Kings gambit Tong
Wu I kind of get it okay let's take a
pawn oh this looks so nice this is so
nice see for coming you see five pawns
are so happy
I just have so many sander plants okay I
can't complain with this I guess it is
more enjoyable to be on material rather
than sacrificing all the material but I
know how my opponent feels let's just
put everything in the center this is how
you control the center you put things in
the center there's so many things in the
center let's play it's just take a free
pawn let's take a free pawn
PPA 3 before
ok pointing sacking take the bishop
first take the night life is pretty good
it's still controlling the center Jaykar
Modi thanks for subbing okay back to
tournament I need to win quick games
first place still in distant reach how
many more games can i play if I average
2 minutes a game that's that's too
optimistic though I just have to I have
to play quickly to play aggressively a
KD 707 welcome back thanks so much for
the bits play od6 I guess ok I'll try
and play aggressively explain I hear 94
I'm not getting mean it I don't think h6
would be terrible now I get me play this
move I would like to open up lines
unfortunately this is probably not a
great approach it's turning into another
gambit okay let's take here Bishop c4
I'll play this attacking this sacking
this so okay let's play c6 I'm gonna
lose a ruck that's okay because I have a
trap they should be four he'll win the
Queen that's nice
okay now light squares are weak for
white I wanna play Queen b5 and made on
e to eventually maybe you rook c1 first
play this first okay now g5 coming King
can't castle either way control both
these squares rook c8 will be yeah the
combination of g5 and rook c8 will be
quite nice if h4 I still play g5 I
believe
that's some nice emotes
I could play that night Stingo I forgot
about that opening it's not a bad choice
of queen d3 Quinn d3 would probably be
simplest if the knight moves okay that's
a tournament let's go 13 place 15 points
13 away so that's like three wins away
three wins yeah okay so there's enough
time I just need this person to stop
winning the e4 I'll play two Knights
attack take their ship t3 edge of g5
okay I think this is supposed to be good
I forget though if it's actually good
I'm opening the H file if Queen Queen
not for g3 okay let's start with check
and then this Queen takes pawn I'll
maybe this move yeah I'm threatening a
very nice move Bishop g8 pawn moves yeah
this should be just deadly the g6 pawn
in the open H file is just a amazing
mating combination and I'm actually
ready to sack like a knight a bishop and
a rook for me my plan as this takes this
takes this takes it's about to happen
Bishop g8 if if takes here Bishop GA
takes here takes here and then mate
[Music]
I don't know if it can be stopped maybe
if I can try but that's not easy
yeah there's there's one move to try and
stop it but okay gave away the night
give away the bishop give away the rook
and queen each 7ob meets okay let's go
8th place 20 points I've only lost two
games I thought I lost more than two
games I felt like I lost a lot of games
hmm maybe the just the losses were more
painful some MMO together
ooh bizarre back that's what I like to
see we need to what is Queenie - I don't
know what this is but I'm just gonna
develop normally and hopefully be
rewarded Castle and play d5 I'm 48
okay I kind of have to slow play this
shapur a5 preventing light from castling
want to take and play Bishop c4 yeah
there we go then I'll win this pawn and
then f2 will fall maybe hopefully it's
gonna put a piece on e3 hmm or not okay
that's meat let's go let's go
some quick wins I'm in contention got
some very quick wins there okay work
again let's be four again mata not from
doesn't matter let's play let's play
this move Croatia
oh this is a gambit what do I do I think
this move takes air there okay and the
Knights
yeah Knight c4 I believe eventually I'd
see 43 and then d3
some move okay reasonable developments
played Bishop III I think I want to play
Queen d2 in queenside castle walking
into a pin maybe that wasn't the
smartest decision but it was a decision
opening the D file if takes have to take
back hmm
I'm still up upon somehow rook t1 coming
I probably won't Castle queenside hey
rook t1 first five is arguably weakening
b5 now diagonals juicy but it's hard to
get to cuz my Knights in the way so
maybe F for coming
ooh what does this move oh this is nice
attacking the Queen block was a little
bit too creative there I'll have Bishop
c4 it with nine of seven and maybe I'll
have a windmill or just free Queen
oh I lose the Queen back I have this
move oh I'm gonna take him and win
everything on the back rank yeah okay up
a full rook I'm trapping this rook -
yeah the knight spin - the rooks trapped
the pawns hanging
I was looking for it to castling there
okay I'm close there's nine minutes left
let's go I had a rough start but trying
to recover winning the tournament would
be the ultimate recovery if you win
cookies for everyone wait that sounds
like amazing incentive work again play
e5 again Stafford gambit again I have to
redeem myself in this opening okay we
have the two knights play though I'm a
d5 or no we have an Italian last time I
played against Italian was against
fiddler
I got crushed with h3 I'm gonna play on
this line h6 and early g5 because I
haven't committed to casting and this
move takes takes mmm let's play this
move I'll accepts slightly damaged pawn
structure
yeah g4 I just want to open the g5 and
rook to e1 or up to Yates Bishop h3
someday and D files now open Queen d6
looks reasonable I'll probably queenside
castle I save the bishop
I should probably save the bishop I can
play rogue g8
yeah and just keep initiative half takes
takes white loses one of the the main
defenders of the Kings side Queen f3
expected I'll sack back fawn hey my
knight spins but that's okay ooh okay
King V Yeats and then eventually okay
let's play this move first I have the
battery but I want the gun I'm losing a
piece losing a piece all that pin is
strong okay let's take care first
okay this is slightly problematic but
the battery is still a battery let's
play this move check and then trying to
think how to deal with this maybe each
five coming I'll sack another pawn just
to open the H file if takes I'll take
here and then hopefully do stuff if that
I can play this move threatening this
move the King can't escape the rookie
one expected rookie one Queen at four
maybe Queen d2 hitting the B to pawn
oh that's good move player gauge six
anyway I freaking won I can take it
yeah let's just go for the O Queen I
fates a problem Knight there there it
looks playable I'm stacking another pawn
wait free Queen I like free Queens
opponents botas ganda did now I want to
go for the kill
let's play this move and then this move
and then this move and then that move
yeah threatening this move
or the smooth
that's nice slightly out of play okay I
could have taken the bishop but going
for me that is to take and then this or
that's okay back to tournament
five minutes left tied for first let's
go oh let's pose Rick again look thank
you for again playing microfiche 1200
let's play hillbilly attack I have six
Queen h4 or wait no Knight f6 I will win
in the game but yeah this is the main
idea now this move I don't think I'm too
too afraid of Knight discoveries Queen
should retreat to g3 at some points
I was hoping to get in one more game
after this one
it's gonna be a close finish
idea about 3s like actually got at the
pond okay I'll take it and then to open
that file play d3 like when g3 now
hitting g7 I'm putting out of three now
395 Bishop h6 ideas
I'm playing aggressively play this move
ooh let's just castle open that file
move back I mean the bishop will come to
d4
let's take hitting this bishop maybe I
don't know
I'll play Knight g5 I want to bring the
rook in rook lift is coming play e5
maybe there's pawns pins of the rook 94
ideas that's enough let's play this move
if takes takes takes and then meet yes
okay dr. turn mix it's got one more game
this person's not this oh this person
wine oh I'm playing this person for
first place maybe I shouldn't bezerk
thank you for I'm not deserting this
very important game also GM Ludo could
potentially catch up lady for others of
g5 Queen d2 I still wanna play
aggressively though I want to play like
each for h5 just go for me
yeah in 94 coming
hmm
okay this is already looking nice
because I have lots of development the
Queen's gonna swing over take some the
95 probably 24 ideas hmm 9 8 7
looking for the knockout blow I'll play
this move first and then f4
[Music]
actually I'll take the pong first as
Queen g5 would have been annoying my
Knights kind of hanging though should
probably play 94 soon tournament time is
ticking
I mean that's good position just don't
know if the game's gonna finish in time
play this move I'm actually sacking at
night yeah this is slightly questionable
I'm down the bishop I'm just going for
the kill
take stakes ooh I don't want to trade
Queens but I might have to let's move
back see a move back again ooh good move
okay I could still avoid the Queen trade
this is very questionable though is very
questionable yeah let's play this move
I'm gonna have to trade Queens Queen f4
I want to still attack ooh slightly
unexpected I'll attack the rook and
threatening rogue h7 still some play I
should win back the piece the bishop is
stuck bishop is actually stuck because
it moves back it cuts off the defense
the term is about to end sure about this
opponent or this saws player name's not
gonna finish I think I have won the
tournaments this game still takes some
work
yeah not sure a block does here work out
seven I check take and then take I'll be
up upon an end
do I want to take the bishop probably
play f3 for good measure f3 is solid and
it's not trade rooks at the pawn
pay for
okay the tournament is over
somehow I like won the tournament was
irking paid off
compact buffalo thanks for the bits I
did lose some rating points but I came
back had some very quick wins in the
middle here Henry Lord baton with five
thousand bits thank you so much have
Henry Lord what time appreciate that
I'll probably put this on youtube
this'll this will be super aggressive
chess in the super blitz arena part
three I did the first two parts a while
ago this is part three maybe I'll do
this as a more regular series so people
on YouTube watching in the future thanks
for watching subscribe comment like
share